good afternoon everyone
um so in this session uh me and my
colleague and um all-time collaborator
from ibm research
german sherman we'll be talking about
applications of ai and machine learning
to mental health
and for me this journey started
i guess more than 10 years ago precisely
because of collaboration
with sharma and many other people
at ibm research and universities
this is really very incomplete list of
collaborators
with germa who gonna talk right after me
of course mentioned first uh the work i
will describe is a very
brief summary of like many years of
research but i just wanted to give you
a kind of a feel for what type of things
and why machine learning can do for
neuroscience research and for practical
applications such as psychiatry
and i usually like to start
any presentation about
ai in psychiatry was this quote from
this famous paper
uh by the ak poland and frank from 2015
where they made this bold claim which is
actually true that psychiatric research
is in crisis
and the case they were making was based
on comparison with
practically any other medical field
where if a patient ever comes to you
with complaints
for example chest pain um imagine a
doctor saying well hmm
let's see maybe let's give you this
medication just in case uh to lower your
blood pressure maybe you have heart
condition
come back in couple of weeks and the
patient comes back and
nothing improved and the pain is getting
worse well maybe let's try this other
medication
like against reflux oh miracle
it did help wonderful and so on
so no other medical field probably would
do things like that without any
objective measurements or
blood work well electrocardiogram if you
suspect that it's
a heart issue or other type of tests
which would make objective measurements
and yet this situation is
still pretty much what's going on in
modern psychiatry
and gesherma gonna talk in much more
detail
about examples of that and what can be
done around that
but this is just to provide you the idea
that
we do need to work on various types of
objective measurements that could help
us
detect uh mental conditions
and just try to recognize what's going
on in the brain from
something more objective than
self-reports
and of course this field of
computational psychiatry
um which is essentially the name of
their department
the group that kisharma is leading at
ibm
and he will talk about that shortly this
is a booming field
and that's precisely the goal of the
field to
improve our current approaches to
diagnosis and hopefully treatment of
mental disorders
by designing and implementing
objective measurements of all kinds and
using
statistical machine learning tools to
analyze those measurements
to help diagnosis prognosis
and hopefully identification of
treatments and the data here
range from anything from classical
functional
magnetic resonance imaging or structural
mri to eeg mhg
and all kind of measurements that can
provide you a signal about what's going
on in the brain
and while gesherma going to talk about
signals that you can extract from
text and speech but i don't want to
kind of give too much out of his
presentation i'll focus a bit more on
more classical
and historically like older approaches
and data modalities
such as mri i also
just wanted to note in the beginning
that this is not just for psychiatry
it's not just for treating patients but
essentially this type of approaches can
be applied to
improve well-being and mental function
of pretty much anyone uh you can
use the data especially those data that
are easy to collect in daily life
uh anything from wearable devices text
speech video and so on and so forth
to improve productivity at work
uh hopefully track and intervene
in terms of stress levels depression and
you name it
there are many applications where this
type of interventions could have been
critical
as we know that severe
kind of tiredness of operators
especially of vehicles and trains
led to various unfortunate accidents
and if any kind of measurements could
have detect a change in their attention
and microsleeps of the operators perhaps
such accidents could have been prevented
there are also
many other applications uh based on
various uh aspects of mental states
whether
emotional response to videos
or to text that could be used um
to decide which advertisement could work
better
or uh perhaps which type of news is
better not to show
the particular person there are many
many applications you can think about
if you have this technology in place
and as i mentioned i kind of wanted to
start a little bit with the history
which is uh
based on our long-term collaboration
with
gujarat his group at ibm
research in yorktown heights
that's also where i spent many years
before moving
last fall to montreal and starting at
the
university of montreal and mila for the
gaya institute
but my previous life and still pretty
much
kind of current collaboration was based
on
using functional mri data and other
brain imaging data
to identify predictive patterns
in various kind of brain data modalities
and make predictions based on those
patterns about
mental states mental disorders and
simply different kind of conditions
and human brains and
just to give you a flavor of what you
can possibly do with machine learning
uh based on various publications that we
had in the past decade you can
quite accurately surprisingly just using
relatively simple methods
like sparse uh regression uh you can
identify
mental states and their changes when
people play video games for example
you can be also quite accurate i'll
mention that in the next few slides
in kind of uh evaluating the level of
such a subjective experience as pain uh
in patients and in just like a regular
subjects
and again the methods used for that
especially in the regimes of small data
may just use relatively simplistic
approaches
not necessarily very deep and very large
scale neural networks
but rather sparse regression with
different additional regularizers
for structure also
you could use methods such as
markov networks and especially sparse
markup network
approaches to identify differences in
brain patterns between controls and
people who suffer from cocaine addiction
and so on and so forth with deep
networks
you definitely can sometimes
achieve better results but provided that
you have more data
as expected and i'll mention example of
that
and uh just to name a few
uh success stories of machine learning
applications it was quite
interesting um when we were able to
identify
basically detect schizophrenia um
and classify patients versus controls
with high accuracy
from very relatively small data sets
and uh when basically looking
at various data other datasets we also
were able to do
pretty good job not just to classify but
also
do symptom severity prediction the list
goes on
and on i just wanted to very briefly
give you
an idea what i'm talking about when i'm
mentioning functional mri
in case not everyone is familiar so this
is essentially
a mri scanner on the left which you
might have experienced in your life and
the functional mri simply means
that their subject is usually spending
12 10 15 minutes in the scanner
uh while doing certain tasks
uh certain activity or sometimes just uh
when the rest so-called resting state of
mri is taken just simply relaxing
and the idea here is that you are
basically taking a
movie of brain activity four-dimensional
signal because you have
three-dimensional uh
kind of image of the brain and over time
it gives you this movie which you
usually try to
correlate in some sense with either
behavior or activity or perception such
as in case of pain
of the subject and the problem with such
data is typically that they're high
dimensional
in terms of the number of the units or
variables uh
three-dimensional pixels or voxels
that still are not high enough
resolution of course to detect
precise neuronal activity they contain
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
neurons
but they measure indirect signal of
neural activity related to blood
oxygenation level
the challenge for machine learning and
statistics with such data is typically
that
number of variables here is that the
order of tens to hundreds of
thousands while number of time points
is maybe at the order of hundreds
maximum thousands and the number of
patients
used to be quite limited to maybe below
100 in each study
but more recently there are larger
larger scale studies
and combination of such data sets
together
is one of the topics of the joint
proposal between
mila and ibm our collaboration with
germa
that we hope to develop in the next
several years on how to come up with
methods for learning robust
models and representations from
heterogeneous
functional mri data sets coming perhaps
from
different locations from different
subjects and perhaps from different
mental conditions so what typically
people look forward in such data well
given some stimulus for example
something
like a video game um or something
causing pain as i'll
mention soon you try to find
relevant areas of the brain that
kind of can be correlated with this
activity and that's a traditional
approach
that's been around for many years but
typically the type of approaches we're
really missing out on a multivariate
nature of the brain where
just finding individual areas
correlating with a signal
with a stimulus is definitely overly
simplistic
so the focus of the modern research in
fmri
is on using multivariate predictive
models
in order to identify multivariate highly
connected patterns of activity with
response to
a particular stimulus or kind of
describing particular behavior
and i probably should really speed up
now
um this is just one old example of
our joint work with collaborators
from northwestern university but it's
just a classical example
of what you might be looking at with
this type of data
you provide subjects in a scanner with
some somewhat uncomfortable
thermal stimulus you heat the metal
plate
on their back not terribly but
sufficiently for them to report
uh their perception of the pain level
and on the right you see
14 different graduate students
um always available for experiments like
that
um reporting there a level of
uncomfortable pain
and there is lots of inter-subject
variability in terms of what they're
reporting
so the question would be like what brain
areas relevant to pain
and can you even predict such a
subjective perception
as pain using the objective signal
fmri and the answer is you can actually
do it quite accurately
and to make a long story short just to
give you some
references to our previous work i just
want to mention that besides using
machine learning and various forms of
sparse regression approaches to predict
from data to the
subjective perception uh it really all
it really helps sometimes to use um
some analytical models and that's kind
of recurrent theme
and some other uh research directions
that we explored
for example if you can manage to model
really well
relationship between temperature and
pain like in this work with gesherma and
collaborators
and essentially is only a few parameters
you can characterize this inter-subject
variability
kind of like a brain print instead of
fingerprint for those subjects
then in combination with purely
data-driven models you achieve
a much higher accuracy of predicting
pain perception from data
so as usual when you combine data-driven
approaches with
some prior expert knowledge uh or
inductive bias
in a sense you may get better results
and as this picture was showing uh
another example
is our uh old collaboration with
mount sinai this work came out several
years ago so in a sense i'm just giving
you a bit of a history of what we used
to
work on in the past decade but it was
interesting
uh study of cocaine addiction
um and basically there was an
interesting hypothesis
by our colleagues from mount sinai
rita goldstein and collaborators that
in terms in case of addiction
such as cocaine you may be able
to actually improve the situation if you
use
medications that have similar action
it's kind of the basically old
idea and hypothesis in addiction
treatment
that sometimes you can use like a
stimulant for stimulant
and the hypothesis here was that the
mechanism of action of cocaine is very
actually similar to
a methylphenidate or italian
which is usually given um in cases of
adhd
but there is important difference that
ritalin acts
much slower and it's kind of half-life
is
an hour and a half to two hours instead
of like 20 minutes
the clearance rate which means that it
doesn't create
addiction and doesn't create the spike
of the interstellar dopamine doesn't
create high and
therefore i mean it can be used as
medications in
case of adhd but on the other hand since
it's quite similar
in terms of action and actually even
molecular structure
was interesting um attempt to try and
see
whether giving ritalin to
uh healthy participants and to cocaine
addicts
may kind of normalize brain activity
in the patients and indeed with machine
learning i mean this lower picture
uh you can see that when you try to
discriminate using different classifiers
uh cocaine addicts versus controls
in their kind of baseline state the
uh classification is much more accurate
than if you give them retalin
they become less distinguishable and
therefore classification falls down so
that was an
interesting two cents towards supporting
that hypothesis
and of course well much more work needs
to be done along those lines
uh before it becomes any practical
treatment but it was interesting to see
and kind of yet another example still
from the
functional mri kind of domain before i
switch to a more recent work
that actually relates to dialogue and
therapy
which i really would like to talk about
um
this was uh one of our earlier works
with
kishirma and his team
on finding out
a really interesting uh kind of example
an experiment
which supported most clearly
what people already kind of
hypothesized about schizophrenia
disorder so schizophrenia seemed to be
like notoriously difficult
and very heterogeneous disorder to
quantify and grammar will talk about
that
in other modalities such as language but
in terms of functional mri
unlike some other disorders it seems to
be not something that
can be associated with some local
abnormalities in brain
and most of the classical methods we're
trying to see
exactly what in the brain gets activated
given the condition or given the task
and
again long story short in that
particular study nothing like that
was to be found when schizophrenic
patients and controls were performing
certain tasks
there was not much difference in terms
of their
local activations but what was
drastically different
apparently was the connectivity pattern
their functional networks
their strengths of connection in terms
of correlation between
uh activations in different parts of the
brain that was strikingly different
not just statistically but also in terms
of
uh being used as predictive features as
discriminative features and that was
like a classical example
really showing that schizophrenia
is truly a network disease and you
cannot reduce
uh the observed phenomenon to just some
local abnormalities
and we were able to achieve like really
high discriminative accuracy using
different machine learning tools from
gaussian markov random fields to svms
actually
again that was relatively small data set
that's why
deep learning methods were very unlikely
to be applicable here
but this um yeah and the kind of
follow-up study
on that which came out um
several years ago in nature
was schizophrenia by the way showing
that not just that discrimination
accuracy
can be high with network features you
can also
uh predict the severity of symptoms
pretty well
but as i said if you start moving beyond
good old relatively small data sets to
somewhat larger data sets and this was
another study with
where we actually had though we had only
13 subjects
the total number of trials was more than
2 000
and with enough regularization and
models appropriate models we were able
to actually use
recurrent coordinates here and
try to figure out what features in
eeg where predictive and how predictive
about different levels of memory load so
this was kind of a success story of
applying
um deep learning to brain imaging data
even despite relatively small data sets
so we were able to improve the accuracy
of detecting
uh different mental load levels by
almost like 10
from the previous state of art and what
was
important here um since this is
application to neuroscience and you want
to know what's
what features in the brain are very
relevant
to this prediction we use the uh
decode net approaches to map uh
our high level features back to brain to
see
uh kind of what made the difference
between the different metal loads
again since i only have probably about
seven minutes left i kind of just wanted
to
wrap up the brain imaging part of the
summary and just make a few points such
as
interpretability such as ability to map
your say deep learning features back to
brain
or the ability to select
out of their inputs variables such as
voxels those are most predictive using
for example sparse regression
is very important in uh health
applications of ai
and in general in any scientific
applications of ai
and that's what you need to keep an eye
on and the main knowledge whether in
form of like some feature engineering or
in form of analytical models like i
briefly mentioned
combined with relatively small data
is typically improving performance as
you would expect
and if you'd like to apply deep learning
to those domains
you need to be aware of a relatively
small data
regime and therefore you need to be
smart about regularization and perhaps
do data augmentation
and you also need to focus on
interpretability
rather than using deep learning as a
black box
and finally i'll just want to give a
very brief
bridge to the next presentation that
germa gonna give
in uh i guess five minutes
and that's switching gears from brain
imaging to other modalities such as
language and more
as he will describe and various
applications to computational psychiatry
so there's just kind of uh
advertisement page with uh incomplete
lists of people
again english group working on this but
their leading intuition here was
that there is a lot of information in
what you say about what and how you
think and what your mental
current mental landscape looks like and
those ideas also inspired us
and particularly uh kind of this project
that was led by
our former uh graduate students hilgard
uh who already graduated from university
of southern california
and basically this was project
on trying to see whether we can
create the dialogue systems for
psychotherapy
uh especially depression
uh because well needless to say the
numbers kind of are
really scary and the predictions made by
world health organization
are sounding very alarming
in terms of supposedly depression
being by 2030 one of the leading cause
of worldwide disability and life loss
uh and supposedly even exceeding some
other
like usual suspects and other disorders
so
uh that's indeed seems to be a kind of
worrisome trend
and the issue is also that
there's such a huge demand and
especially i mean
lately with covet and social isolation
unfortunately depression is on the rise
but
it's very very difficult to match
this demand with a supply of um
basically professionals therapists and
even if you find a good therapist
and you have an access
nobody can really track your condition
24 7.
that's why any use of automated tools
might be helpful they're not going to
replace a therapist but they really
might be helpful in terms of providing
some intermediate support and collecting
data that can be later
also used by healthcare professional
but the gap between supply and demand
in this area is huge so given this
motivation
and given some publicly available data
sets that we looked at
for example this data from alexander
street
uh which contained about 400 sessions of
depression therapy between patients and
therapists that we looked at uh they
kind of made us think about
particular particular properties of this
type of dialogue that
may require um kind of
specific type of models although we all
know that
the deep learning especially with recent
successes of extremely large scale
models
such as gpt3 i mean 175 billion
parameters
and data being pretty much the whole
internet
out there while those systems really
achieve
really amazing results and can generate
essays that are impossible to
distinguish from
in many cases and possible in some cases
possible but
pretty good essays that almost look like
written by
a well-educated human and so on so forth
those systems still rely on large data
which is again not necessarily always
the case
in medical health applications like this
for example
therapy data sets we only had about uh
400 sessions
and roughly 40 000 interactions between
patient and therapists or kind of uh
question reply pairs or samples
so in this setting we kind of decided to
develop
somewhat different type of model i will
not go into details
but the model was smaller and it was
based on another principle
for building representations not the
large-scale deep network with hundreds
of layers but rather
a hash code based approach which would
map
the input text into high level
representations as well
but using different techniques and also
what's important we
try to impose uh the property of those
representations which would make
therapies responses more aligned
as is supposed to be with what the
patient is saying and as a proxy for
alignment we used
mutual information between the
representation
in the representation space of what the
patient is saying
and what the therapist is supposed to
reply again the details are in the paper
but essentially we were
very pleased to see that in comparison
to
various at that point state-of-the-art
models
and this picture on the right this
relatively small
parameter-wise model was really able to
capture this again relatively small data
set much better and generate responses
that were both diverse and
appropriate as measured uh well kind of
by mechanical third we
really were asking humans to rate
performance of different systems which
are on the x-axis
of the uh bottom right plot
uh so not only based on those kind of
metrics
we saw like really clear improvement we
also looked into
what type of responses was were
generated
and uh kind of this is an example of the
dialogue between patient and therapies
this particular interaction while
several
flavors of our system there were several
versions
generated uh to different extent
reasonable replies while unfortunately
plain vanilla lstm approach just could
not learn
anything from this small data set and
generated some repetitive
meaningless sentence and more advanced
methods that we compared with
unfortunately
we're also generating not very
informative or appropriate answers
most of the time the same ones
uh basically showing that they were just
unable to learn from this
relatively small data set there were
also some funny examples
uh which were not intended but i just
wanted to put it here
because it was quite hilarious to see
the system well unintentionally
uh giving some sarcastic answer or
humorous answer to a patient
complaining about difficulty of getting
therapy
which we all know about and i just
mentioned and the system suggested
suggesting that maybe medications should
be tried like forget about therapy
anyway but seriously example was just
showing that
hashcode based approaches that i
mentioned at least were able to generate
reasonable responses and those responses
were
varying across patients while
large-scale deep networks
with this small amount of data were not
a good match
and i think i just would like to
probably stop here
with this final slide about
the vision of the future that ideally
and with
quite a large market for that it would
be nice to
continue developing approaches like that
because
as i mentioned the
current situation of the number of
people who really would benefit from
therapy sessions and the number of
practitioners who can provide such
therapy this gap is huge and
even if you can match people with
therapies you still
cannot track at finer
granularity at the matter of hours
changes in mental states of people
and kind of nobody will be able to talk
to them
multiple hours a day so in this
situation
a more automated approach which could
collect the data
on regular basis well store them
privately perhaps
maybe only share them with healthcare
practitioner
and also provide some intermediate with
data gathering intermediate
somewhat simplistic support
and perhaps interventions or alerting
health care
providers based on those dialogues this
type
this type of automation probably would
be
very very useful especially as i
mentioned with increasing
demand for such services
anyway at this point i would like to
stop
and i will stop sharing the screen
and i guess we will switch to germa's
slides right now
so
[Music]
so i don't know how we go about
questions or this is probably
yeah the questions will be later on
but in any case i think that at this
point yeah usually we'll be just sharing
yes
presenting there we go
okay so and you see
yes yes yeah i i see it really well
you see the sidebar or you see you see
the sidebar right
i do see the sidebar okay now it should
be
not anymore and we have
until uh
3 20. i think we have until three oh
yeah 320.
yeah okay okay let me get started
uh so thanks uh irina for all the
mention of our work together and
you mentioned that um it was somewhat
infected with
psychiatry and i had to say that
more than infected that was exposed for
the first time to machine learning
uh through you and that had a
very significant uh very significant
consequences
my background is in physics
but also i did i studied
in psychiatry so it's a combination of
many different things
that give rise to what we are doing and
uh i'll be talking about things that are
very
relatively recent uh coming out
of our group in ibm um
and it's mostly
uh as edina was saying mostly
a center around the study of
language in particular more generically
behavior
that is i'll show results mostly around
language
and just 41 a little bit of background
in the us alone
there are more than 63 million
interviews uh career uh
related to mental health conditions
between patients
and clinicians um and this is the
by far by you know by wide margin
the main form of assessing the state of
a patient
the progression the the effects of
therapy
um and
what is interesting is that this
methodology
hasn't really changed in a long time
for several reasons um
that um you know have a long time to
discuss
but what is interesting is that very few
of these interviews are analyzed
in the ways that we know how to analyze
language production
now what is that we have in mind
and uh we divided
our presentation with arena uh
understanding i would focus more on the
on the things that we are doing that are
closer to clinical applications
and so i think i think it's important to
understand what is that we want to
achieve
and one main focus is
precisely is assessment
so current assessment is
essential you need the coincidence in
time and place between the patient and
the condition
is it really labor intensive
and it's unreliable in uh in the sense
that this little uh iterator inc
consistency right is it's reliable this
is like
you know clinician and psychiatrist
neurologist they really know
uh the problem how to identify
symptoms etc but uh there are different
schools there are different
degrees of of understanding
you have trainees you have people with
you know decades of experience
um so this is what we are trying to
focus our efforts in
improving systematizing assessment
there are things this is what we want to
do and there are things that we don't
want to do
that this is a very complex problem it's
it's
becoming it's coming to the surface and
and this is something that we are
discussing very intensely in ibm in
particular
that uh in in what respects this work
uh we are aligned behind
the ethical principles of
medicine and clinical research right so
we are thinking
as of ai as a tool for clinical use
right and and as such uh we abide by
my principles are well established and
given that there are
new things that we can do uh we have to
be careful
not to breach or those principles uh
with new technology that was not present
when those principles were designed
um as i was saying
you know language and the dialogue
between the patient and the clinician is
the main form of assessment
outside of the clinic as if we all know
you know
language evaluation is
present everywhere right so you know
social media and
uh you know games you know it's it's
everywhere
right so one of the things that
we're trying to do is to to essentially
close this gap
between what goes on in the clinic
and what goes on outside of the clinic
and in a way we also want to bring
extend the reach of the clinic extend
the reach
of and psychiatrists outside
by using technologies that we are using
to
uh to suggest someone uh to buy
nike as opposed to adidas um
so what is that we do well we take
speech samples from patients
and we throw it at it everything we know
and everything that we don't know what i
mean by
that so as you know we have very well
established tools
for natural language processing we have
new tools
uh being developed visa mentioned
for instance p2p3 um we have
a huge amount of tools for the study of
voice production i have to relate our
voice nuances prosody to
emotionally conquest aspects but we have
things that we don't know
in ai that are well
known or well established in psychiatry
just to give an example that i would not
mention uh
in detail later is you know
patients who suffer psychosis are known
to
have a different way of understanding
and producing metaphors
so one thing that we try to do is well
can we
devise a good method to identify
metaphors
and then apply that to uh to the patient
population and see if we can measure it
so like i said you know we
try to mine as much information as
possible
from language production language
understanding
uh and using increasingly
other sense of data so i'll mention
very briefly so let me start so in some
examples
you know this will be a bit shallow
because we want to
give an exposure of how we're going
about
this research how we're thinking about
it
and you can always if you're interested
to see the papers
so this is something that we have done
relatively recently and
we have the challenge of understanding
uh the possible fate of uh
cohort that is world characterized in in
psychiatry and it's called
clinical high risk for psychosis these
are typically adolescents
they have self-rational symptoms of
psychosis
and but eventually some of them we have
a first
episode of psychosis and most likely or
become permanently schizophrenic right
so that would require
uh uh treatment uh appropriate treatment
so what uh we showed is that take it
based on interviews
uh with people the these people speak
about themselves for half an hour or so
and taking concepts that are well known
in psychiatry such as
what's called derailment or flight of
ideas and people are incoherent
uh disturbance of of
the self measured by how often
or how little they talk about themselves
and
what concepts and poverty of speech the
fact that
a symptom seems to be
a speech that is very impoverished and
simple
so using a formalization of these
three features we were able to
predict conversion
of the onset of the clauses within a
two-year
window after uh the baseline interviews
and we were able to extrapolate between
different uh cohorts in different
studies
but also very significant accuracy so uh
suggesting that that these features
might be
possible to be identifiable
independent of the exact context of how
speech is elicited in these patients
um so a very different direction
and one that to some extent is um
it's uh it's better control
because you know these labels of having
a
psychotic event or being schizophrenic
or being
manic uh are a bit difficult in this
case
we have more control and
what we have uh in these experiments is
patients who are regular uses of drugs
uh
recreational drugs or drugs of abuse
that are given uh
in a in the blind double-blind
experiment
pill that could be ecstasy
technical names and dna oxytocin
or placebo and we are also
using in some of the experiments other
drugs cocaine
uh um metaphetamine
and then we ask them to talk about
someone who's close to them so a
spouse or a parent or a friend
to elicit emotional responses and then
similar to what i was describing before
we take things that are known in
in in the literature about the effect of
ecstasy in in how you process emotion
convert that into features through
semantic embedding
then take also velocity features
uh related to uh spectral features but
also
the distribution of passes for instance
that convey a huge amount of information
regarding emotional content and based on
that
we can identify again with high accuracy
the condition whether they ingested uh
one of the drugs or injustice
the placebo of pills but also
creates a map sort of the many follow
how you can compare one drug versus the
other eventually
how these people can if they are taking
different drugs or traversing
that manifold over time
or us you know they are affected by
therapy
uh to to withdraw etc
um another direction so i
was i talked about a psychiatric
condition
like schizophrenia uh a condition
uh that is manipulated by drugs
and might be considered eventually an
addiction
depending on how they use it
and now i can mention a few things about
the neurological disorder in this case
is parkinson
so here what we are doing
is trying to see to what extent
using a minimal
repeatable simple and perhaps engaging
speech samples or speech problems
uh how much we can say about the status
the status of a patient with parkinson's
and so we have some work
uh indicating that uh just by using very
short
uh prompts like asking
uh someone to talk about the typical day
in their life
we can get a significant difference of
the scale of the deterioration the
clinical scale of deterioration
and we can also identify
whether the patients have
uh ingested the the therapeutic drug in
this case
uh it's dopamine replacement something
that
uh uh it it takes in in
some of the people suffering parkinson's
uh whether they are
on devadopa or of levadopa
similarly using a very simple prompt or
something that you can do in one minute
and there is
in particular describing a simple
picture like a cartoon
and with that between
semantic aspects syntactic
aspects that are also altered by
parkinson's and bodybuilding
and possibly so which is more
understandable changes in
voice articulation we have enough to uh
uh obtain a very considerable accuracy
at determining
whether they are in on on and off state
and the goal of that is that you can
deploy
this uh tool in a click on trial and
that's precisely
uh what we are doing uh in a couple of
those
ongoing clinical studies that we're
engaged in
as we speak so another way to
think about it's particularly for the
case of pakistan but
it goes beyond uh so what we have here
is that
uh we have arkansasian people
in different languages and what i show
you in the previous slide
actually was originally uh recorded in
spanish but
the type of analysis that we do is
really
impervious to the translation so we can
apply the same analysis
in the original spanish translate to
english apply the same analysis and get
the same results
but of course you know we're talking
about
in the european languages uh so
the challenge is how far you can go
in terms of uh understanding
commonalities
so we have shown here is that you can
take
um syntactic features
again we are talking about uh in
european languages
spanish german and czech and extract
uh morphological syntactic
morphological features uh
using the same procedure for extracting
those
uh in uh using databases
understanding the normative values of
those
features uh from databases
in the corresponding language and then
uh and show that we can uh
using that in serve uh with a
good accuracy the scale
of the deterioration um
based on how these are distorted
and they're more distorted as the
deterioration progresses
so this is not the ultimate
goal the ultimate goal for us to
understand whether there are
universal models true universal models
that we could apply
to any language including languages
that are not necessarily in the european
but
this is not exactly but this is a step
towards that uh and
and uh by understanding that there are
you know we can then define certain
commonalities in terms of the patterns
but of course
the languages are are to some extent
very different uh so the challenge for
us is to see
you know what is the right way of
understanding
universality maybe there is not
necessarily such universality
uh given how complex
different languages can be and how that
might interact with the condition itself
so if it's staying for a moment
with parkinson's given that it's a it's
a good example
of a condition that affects not only
motor function but also
cognition and emotion right that
ultimately
you know for certain theories of of
brain function
they're all related that every brain
function is somehow
related to uh motion
motor or sensory motor processing so in
this case
uh what we decided to do
is to understand to what extent
one can take
videos or actually even pictures of
parkinsonian people and
and say something about the condition
so uh what we did here is a nice trick
so
we created a
standard deep learning approach to
strength features from pictures
collected from video clips
and then train that with which labels
using youtube youtube videos of people
who serve
describe are subscribed as parkinsonian
so
there's quite a number of them because
people really want to
contribute somehow to the understanding
of the disease
to the stigmatization etcetera so there
is a
large number of uh videos of people who
claim to be perplexing but of course
they're not clinically validated there's
no clinical validation
and we saw that we could use that and
and then after training it we apply this
to
a clinically validated
data so we essentially show that
we can match and in some cases surpass
the judgment of the commission that will
see the exact same video
right both in terms of identifying
whether someone is a patient or is a
control
or using similar data to what it's
called before
understanding whether someone is on the
drug
the the the the
replacement drug or off the drive and as
a cute example
uh because we have a the direct
connection with the actor alan alda
we took uh videos from his
interviews you know his career as an
actor spending several decades
uh showing that we can
uh very quickly identify
uh when he was diagnosed
with parkinson um which was around
2014 2015 so we see that just taking
random interviews that he he gave over
the years
we can see that our
weekly label train approach
can detect the presence of parkinson's
in uh in his face in the way
uh he expresses uh the face the secret
actually the sequences
the sequence of faces that are expressed
in the video this is not entirely a
dynamic model but
it's a statistical model based on the
sequence of
of uh faces
uh so you know staying in um
in okay so we have a very short time
uh sustained with uh uh you know logical
disorders
uh something that uh we've been doing
uh in the last three four years is
understanding to what extent we can do
something similar to what we did in
particular for
cognitive impairment so we show that
taking just a syntactic uh the
composition
of the the sentences that people produce
when they are asked to describe that
picture that you see
on the left now as you can see this
is from a study that was started in the
40s
so we can get uh close to 70 percent
accuracy at infinite the minimum
of state which is a scale
of uh
cognition impairment that is used
regularly to assess
uh quantum impairment and again this is
based only on the structure so there's
no
semantic content at all
that in the world that actually is going
to
be published tomorrow we were able to
access
a database that precisely goes back
several decades and we show that we can
take
a sample of this description task where
people
are asked to talk about that picture
when a person was
considered by the neurologist to be
cognitively healthy and predict
whether they will have a late
or an early onset of alzheimer's
defined by whether you develop it before
or after 85 years old
with an auc of 74
over 50 when
if we collect all the clinical
information available
uh all the neuro psychology stats uh uh
all the demographics etc you only get to
uh
sixty percent and you'll see of 60.
and again this is based on just a
single a single uh
picture description uh when they were
considered
healthy so the the possibility
of using these not to predict
alzheimer's because
that's not the point but to use this as
a measure of
uh progression of the condition and
effect of therapy
that can be used regularly
is the actual goal of of this work and
and in fact let me skip over this this
is something that
we are doing uh as we speak
with the uh true foundations actually
that
are following patients with als
blueberries disease sleeping hopkins
disease
and we monitor how they're progressing
on a weekly basis using just a
smartphone
and applying all the knowledge that we
accumulated
over uh neurological disorders uh in
order to
track uh how fast uh or how slow
uh they're progressing uh in the disease
that
in turnkeys you can go really fast and
and then
eventually understand whether any
therapies
is taking an effect and in the interest
of time
uh we'll stop uh because we are
a bit over time oh nice to see you
so talk to you soon i guess
okay bye